[Música]
[Aplausos]
o avançado sabe o quanto a cidade pode
ter idéias e
[Música]
pensou cláudio mas não solta o áudio que
vocês conseguem ler
na verdade eu sou claude que carrega o
que cada um de vocês carrega o potencial
da vida e estou mostrando pra vocês
ainda quando criança eu recebi o
diagnóstico de uma doença rada e uma
doença grave chamada neutra fisipe a
muscular infantil uma doença que
acarreta em destruição dos neurônios
motores com isso
progressivamente pede a pessoa perde o
movimento se pede capacidades militares
mesmo diante dessas dificuldades
a minha mãe viu a escola a possibilidade
de fazer amigos que eu poder brincar e
conhecer pessoas
mas mesmo tendo plenas capacidades
cognitivas e também tendo apenas
capacidade de comunicação
eu encontrei dificuldade de inclusão
escolar
mas a minha mãe não desistiu várias
escolas até enquanto é algo que me
admitir o terceiro ano que eu comecei
meus colegas
o professor criou um projeto chamado de
dente do dia
era um dia para cada colega também
auxiliando alcançados materiais e levado
para o pátio auxiliar nas brincadeiras
então na hora do recreio todas as
brincadeiras e um se adaptando inclusive
pela corda amarelinha pega-pega
brincadeira que eu mais gostava de
pega-pega pegava minha cadeira e poucas
vezes
a cadeira tem um desnível do pat
michel ficava como qualquer criança que
cheguei à escola pública
no entanto no meu primeiro dia de aula
elevador e chegando
blá blá
então mostra grande mãe eu vou fazer
faculdade
amanhã eu vou me inscrever para o
vestibular
mas mesmo a inscrição ainda é desafiador
então nossa casa da família já que o
poder público de transporte viável que
me pegasse em casa ao invés de adaptar
todos os ônibus
então tinha toda que eu queria estava
matriculado tinha transporte
bastava eu aproveitar a oportunidade
chegando em todos os desafios que nós
vimos ea universidade que oferece a ele
uma bolsa de estudos
assim é óbvio
em pouco tempo a capacidade de escrever
como as outras pessoas então existia era
na testa ou segurava a boca maldita e
apertando os botões do teclado do
computador notebook ninguém então eu ia
à biblioteca pegava livros informática e
utilizando o computador eu me dei conta
usando a calculadora do computador
eu percebi o que existe um programa que
o aperto que eu clico com o mouse um
botão e aparece número porque não é um
problema que eu clico no botão e aparece
livre
então eu comecei a estudar sozinho como
fazer programas computacionais e
desenvolvi meu primeiro programa chamado
music
esse problema tem todo o lado
[Música]
eu coloquei em volta de cada vez
o novo programa de computador desde
simples movimento de um olho de um dedo
enfim permitir que as pessoas possam
escrever
de início eu também não era a
competitividade do mercado de trabalho
em fazer diversas acadêmicos então
estágios acadêmicos e voluntários que
reúne experiência
conhecimento que os espaços e não
permite a minha exclusão desafio eu
encontrava nas tecnologias demonstrar
meu potencial eu aprendi depende de mim
o tamanho dos obstáculos
se não tivéssemos enfrentado todos os
desafios ainda tivesse desenvolvido
tecnologia educacional hoje eu estou
internacional de pesquisa de tecnologia
que busca teria sido o primeiro a
universidade federal já
já superei
[Música]
preconceitos e tudo isso leva a crê que
são decisões e não às nossas condições
que determina até aonde gente pode
chegar no futuro próximo
quero continuar aprofundando agora nos
estudos de doutorado e quero poder
escrever possível na história de
prováveis impossíveis
[Aplausos]
ah